even tom hanks tom hanks
once the most trusted best best-liked
man in the country
according to polls is cancelled
he is or they're at least trying to
cancel them tom hanks is a super
lib super duper lib raises money for
democrats he just recently just a couple
of weeks ago
wrote an erotic essay for the new york
times about the tulsa race riot
and how white people need to feel bad or
something
but he's not he's not anti-racist the
left contends
he's not racist but he's not anti-racist
and frankly if you ask me that's just as
bad
as being a racist resource i don't even
know i don't even know what that means
anymore now
in the author's defense the author who
accused tom
tom hanks rather of not being
anti-racist
tom hanks is the father of chet hanks
and chet hanks
did formally declare white boy summer
hey guys
um look i just wanted to tap in really
quick i just got this feeling man
um that this summer is uh
it's about to be a white boy summer you
know
take it how you want i'm not talking
about like trump uh
you know nascar type white i'm talking
about you know
you know me um john b
jack harlow type white boy summer you
know what i mean let me know if you guys
uh
can vibe with that and get ready
you know because i am yeah i am too chet
i
man chet sign me up i don't do i count i
don't know i'm a little
especially during the summer i get quite
quite dark so i if i can be vibin
with you and mr harlow and to then
absolutely sign me up
watching that video i i do wonder
have chet and tom hanks ever spoken to
one another can you imagine can you just
close your eyes and imagine a situation
in which chet and tom anks have a
conversation
because i i can't imagine that but i
would very much like to
it is it would be a very funny company
so anyway okay
chet hanks the founder of white boy
summer is uh
tom's son but that's not why that is not
the reason
that the left is angry at tom hanks for
not being
anti-racist the reason is that in his
career his
gigantic long-lasting film career tom
hanks has played white people
who do the right thing this article
going around
saying that tom hanks is
not an anti-racist that is why the left
is upset with him right now
this is the thesis this is his big
transgression
quote over the years tom hanks has
starred in a lot of big movies about
historical events including saving
private ryan greyhound forrest gump
apollo 13
bridge of spies and news of the world he
has served as a producer executive
producer on even more films and tv shows
based on american history including band
of brothers
the pacific john adams and from the
earth to the moon he was an executive
producer of documentaries such as the
assassination of president kennedy
and the 60s on cnn in other words
he is a baby boomer star who has built a
sizable part of his career
on stories about american white men
doing the right thing
and that that's the problem apparently
apparently right now in our culture
it is not permissible to believe
that white men can do the right thing
because this apparently erases that's
the that's the verb they like
it erases black voices and the voices of
women and
do you remember some years ago now not
that long ago
there was the daniel day lewis lincoln
movie
and this was protested by people on the
far left
because it suggested that abraham
lincoln freed the slaves
which obviously he did but they didn't
like that
because the far left said no no the
slaves freed themselves you're erasing
the contributions
of black people and women and i don't
know whoever tibetans i don't think they
were involved but it's got to be
everybody other than a white guy
and it's just not true abraham lincoln
freed the slaves he did it it was him
it was basically only him it was him and
all the soldiers overwhelmingly white
who he called into battle that's what
happened that's a nice thing isn't that
in a
in a society where
we think about our past we think about
our future we're bound together as
countrymen isn't that a nice thing to
say
one group of people did a thing for
another group of people
but we're not allowed to believe that
anymore because everything has to be
focused only on one the tyranny of our
own will
and our own ability to save ourselves
without accepting grace from anybody
else
and everything has to be about vicious
racism and division
and no group of people can ever do
anything to another group for another
group of people
tom hanks canceled at least according to
the far left he'll probably survive it
he's powerful enough but
the the thesis i think is much more
widespread
hey i am so pleased that you have
enjoyed this content you've watched it
through to the end you want more but
you're not getting more
because you haven't rung the bell you
got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe
you got to like it you got to get the
notifications then i would suggest maybe
head on over
to apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify myspace xanga
anywhere you got the michael knowles
show audio podcast and
while you're at it you can pre-order my
upcoming books speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
only for a few more days thank you we'll
see you next time